et
[Musique]
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous benoît
victime bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau
merci d'être là vous êtes grand reporter
prix albert londres correspondant du
quotidien français le monde en russie
votre dernier livre les loups vient de
sortir aux arènes dans la collection
équinoxe vous auriez voulu faire un
livre plus dans l'actualité vous
n'auriez pas pu on va y revenir dans un
instant on a vu dans le journal damien
cottier à l'instant ces images troupes
russes qui recule de la frontière
ukrainienne y compris ce matin en clean
et dans crime et il ya ces mots de
vladimir poutine ces dernières heures
nous ne voulons pas la guerre attention
c'est la question à un million de
roubles est-ce que la désescalade être
amorcées dans l'est de l'ukraine oh
c'est pas moi qui vais vous le dire mais
en plus je pense qu'on sera tous
d'accord on s'est un peu focalisés
depuis ces dernières semaines mais
particulièrement ces derniers jours sur
les moindres signaux les moindres
déclarations qui avaient l'air très
inquiétante c'était ça ne s'était pas de
l'alarmisme c'était inquiétant il faut
pas tomber dans l'excès inverse de le
moindre signe d'un apaisement
considérer que tout est réglé dès la
plupart des experts notamment côté russe
prévenait depuis assez longtemps que ce
bras de fer durer pendant des mois et
avec des faces chaudes des phases un peu
moins chaude apparemment mais même ça il
faut être prudent parce que on voit des
troupes qui partent en continuant voir
qui arrive apparemment peut-être on
débute une phase un peu moins chaude
avec deux éléments dans les dernières
heures pour le coup qui peuvent faire
réagir d'abord cette cyberattaque en
ukraine peut-être on peut en dire un mot
et puis la demande si ça avec des
guillemets de la douma fait à vladimir
poutine de reconnaître les territoire
séparatiste pro-russe de donetsk est
lougansk quelle lecture on peut faire de
ça la cyberattaque je serai pas vous
dire et le l'initiative de la douma
alors l'initiative c'est un bien grand
mot c'est quand même
parlement croupion qui fait ce qu'on lui
dit il fait depuis le début la stratégie
d'eads et des russes c'est de placer
dans les mains de vladimir poutine le
maximum d'outils possible d' instrument
de pression de négociations selon qu'on
est optimiste ou poli est ensuite libre
au président de les utiliser dans ce
bras de fer avec les occidentaux là on
place entre ses mains un outil
supplémentaire plutôt lourd plutôt
sérieux alors il fait moins peur que le
canon d'un charme et ce serait si
poutine décidé de suivre la douma et de
reconnaître l'indépendance de ces deux
républiques autoproclamées ce serait une
escalade appelons-la diplomatique qui
serait qu'ils seraient sérieuses quand
même mais là pour le coup sahara
enterrerait vraiment les accords de
minsk qui prévoit non seulement le
cessez le feu mais aussi une espèce de
statut pour le coup au sein de l'ukraine
alors bon on est tenté de dire que la
russie n'y aurait pas vraiment intérêt
après on sait que c'est chacun mesure
différemment ce à quoi il a intérêt est
ce les décisions qu'il prend et puis
dans le fond ça ne change absolument
rien au fond précisément est au coeur du
problème c'est à dire l'obsession
ukrainienne de vladimir poutine à votre
livre je vous cite benoît vitkine ce
sont des propos que vous prêtez à
vladimir poutine donc à vrai dire dans
l'esprit du président russe l'idée même
de paepe l'ukrainien est une vue de
l'esprit l'indépendance ukrainienne a
été une nouvelle trahison de ce pleutre
de gorbatchev et des occidentaux à
présent ceux ci cherchent à attirer
l'ukraine dans leurs filets à lui
peut-il de rétablir la balance c'est
bien là le problème je fait pire que lui
attribué des propos je lis dans son
esprit là mais c'est assez facile parce
que poutine s'exprime effectivement
beaucoup beaucoup sur l'ukraine et avec
ce type de propos c'est à dire que le
selon lui l'ukraine est une incongruité
une incongruité historique un pays dont
la souveraineté est factice d'autant
plus quand elle le veut se rapprocher
des occidentaux est alors le livre il
aborde sa messi il aurait pu être
beaucoup plus dans l'actu puisque moi je
me place quand même il ya encore
quelques années
ça permet peut-être de comprendre des
choses de la situation actuelle dans le
sens où c'est on est encore à l'époque
de l'ukraine rêver de vladimir poutine
dans le sens où c'est une ukraine à qui
on peut pardonner cette insolence qui
est son indépendance à qui on peut
pardonner sa sa souveraineté à partir du
moment où elle est limitée parce que je
décris du fonctionnement de ce pays à
savoir la très grande corruption le
règne de le règne des oligarques et ça
ce sont des règles que poutine et ses
hommes connaissent et avec lesquels ils
aiment jouer des oligarques ça se
manipule ça s'achète ça se fait chanter
et ça ça permet de garder une main très
forte en ukraine quand ce pays soyons
prudents 1 décide essaye ambitionne de
choisir un modèle un peu différent c'est
en soi une menace pour les russes une
menace parce qu'un modèle alternatif
c'est une menace et c'est une façon
supplémentaire de se détacher de la
russie dangereuse pour moscow le fait de
refuser à l'ukraine çà çà çà sont
crédités je ne sais pas comment le dire
c'est une c'est une obsession
personnelle de poutine qui n'a jamais
fait le deuil de l'urss où elle est
partagée par beaucoup de gens ici c'est
les deux ce serait ce serait difficile
d'imaginer qu'ils soient en décalage
complet avec
des sentiments profonds des choses assez
profondément ancrées c'est ce que dit
poutine nous seuls nous sommes un seul
et même peuple ça peut on peut
l'entendre en russie assez fréquemment
dit parfois un peu différent on est un
peuple frère nous sommes des peuples
frères le problème c'est que mon et
peuples frères qui se font la guerre
depuis quelques années avec une cassure
générationnel un net pour le coup ou pas
oublier absolument bien sûr les jeunes
n'ont pas du tout ce ressenti parce
qu'ils n'ont pas la même expérience
et puis à l'heure en plus les questions
pas tout ça mais dans leur grande
majorité ces questions de statut ces
questions finalement deux visions très
impérial
ça leur parle moins et est ce que le
fait que que poutine du coup aille dans
ce sens de l'autre côté de la frontière
côté ukrainien ça renforce un sentiments
nationalistes ukrainiens d'ailleurs plus
que pro occidental bien sûr c'est là
c'est là
que l'on pourrait faire la liste des
succès et des échecs de poutine dans ce
dossier majeur pour lui depuis des
années c'est sans doute le plus grand
échec avec une politique de
déstabilisation qui est passé y compris
par la guerre celle dans le donbass
poutine selon la formule 1 peut
consacrer a perdu le cren perdu les
ukrainiens imaginer que comme des pions
on peut les orienter d'un côté puis de
l'autre c'est son illusion c'est le
c'est un monde c'est son monde mais qui
correspondent à aucune réalité sauf que
là encore en ukraine il ya une fracture
alors c'est peut-être très schématique
mais à l'ouest de l'ukraine on serait
plutôt pro occidental et alès pour le
coup il ya des réalités prorisque sait
on sait il ya une réalité ça il ya une
fracture qui qui qui lie à comment dire
oui à dd c'est un patchwork culturelle
linguistique etc ce pays mais bon ça n'a
pas forcément page pas forcément un pays
de fonctionner mais le constat est le
même c'est à dire que cette fracture
elle a au contraire diminué immensément
depuis l'agression russe a alors il ya
le caractère russe de l'ukraine sur
lequel vladimir poutine ne veut pas
lâcher il ya aussi vous le disais tout à
l'heure le risque peut-être démocratique
une russie trop pro occidental pourrait
faire peser sur l'intérieur de la russie
est ce que c'est une réalité comment
pour le coup ça pourrait se manifester
alors ça cce là pour le coup ça il
s'agit vraiment de de lire dans l'esprit
de poutine encore une fois avec un peu
moins d'éléments mais c'est ce qu'on
peut imaginer c'est à dire qu'à partir
du moment où poutine et une partie des
russes décrivent l'ukraine comme en
réalité un une partie de la russie son
ancêtre historique mais aussi un peuple
vraiment tout à fait comparable si ce
pays arrivé à
choisir un modèle de développement
complètement différent en terme de
démocratie d'état de droit de lutte
contre la corruption ce serait un signal
envoyé à la population russe très
parlant beaucoup plus que quand par
exemple l'estonie réussi une transition
passe soviétique ce serait un signal à
la population est donc un danger pour ce
régime qui justifie sa spécificité en
disant ce modèle occidental il n'est pas
pour noah alors la question inverse se
pose en ukraine et c'est en partie le
sujet de votre livre pour faire un
résumé en suit présidente élue de
l'ukraine plutôt effectivement très
maidan si vous vous raccrochez à la
réalité dans les jours qui précèdent sa
prestation de serment présidente que les
loups à la fois les hommes du kremlin et
les oligarques un monde d'hommes
d'ailleurs compte bien tout faire pour
empêcher d'accéder au pouvoir la
question c'est comment une société
démocratique en tout cas à ce point
gangréné par ce qui est un vieux monde
corrompu ou du moins qu'il a longtemps
été peut se construire peut avancer il
donne dans mon livre il en est pas
encore là c'est à dire que avant même de
savoir si le pays peut se transformer
celle qui vient d'en être élue
présidente elle même ne fait jamais
vraiment le choix est ce qu elle veut
être une femme d'état qui va essayé
d'impulser un mouvement profond comme ça
ou bien est-ce qu'elle va rester une
autre de ses hommes slash femme
d'affaires rusé et qui aura mis la main
sur un levier supplémentaire du pouvoir
et c'était vraiment le moment d'ambition
première dans ce livre l'aspect russo
ukrainien idée là parce qu'on peut pas
parler du crâne sans parler de russie et
que ces acteurs russes 1 ce sont des lui
parmi d'autres mais l'élu qui moi me me
fascine le plus ce sont ces oligarques
ukrainiens qui ont déjà à titre
individuel un mode de fonctionnement 1
impasse et davy absolument
extraordinaire sans les romantiser et
justement je voulais pas romantiser je
voulais montrer ce que c'est qu'un pays
soumis à un système comme vous dites
gangréné ce qu'est la corruption la
grande corruption par la corruption
telle qu'on la conçoit chez nous il ya
quand même une différence pas seulement
de 2 2 niveaux d'échelle mais vraiment
une différence fondamentale désolé
guerre ukrainien nerfs pour revenir en
2022 et qui ont été accusés se quitter
le navire quand ça commençait un peu à
sentir mauvais du côté de la frontière
est non plus ou moins non non ils jouent
leur carte ils trouvent toujours un
moyen de s'en sortir c'est le principe
bien sûr pour revenir aujourd'hui quel
projet de nations aussi c'est la
question qui se pose on peut construire
en ukraine pour le coup sur fond de
guerre imminente permanente avec le
risque permanent pour le coup d'être
amputé une partie de leur territoire on
parlait la crimée à l'instant est ce que
le décret ne les ukrainiens ont fait le
deuil de ce morceau de leur pays comme
ils devront peut-être faire le deuil
l'est de leur pays comment on fait pour
sommes avancées en tant que nation en
tant que territoire difficilement et
c'est d'ailleurs la stratégie de poutine
la menace permanente un conflit plus
larvé enfin un conflit larvé dans l'est
et une partie du territoire amputé la
crimée oui c'est a fait quelques bâtons
dans les roues quand on a l'ambition de
changer radicalement un modèle de
société qui est 30 ans de pause
soviétisme corrompu corrompu 80 ans de
totalitarisme derrière ça fait des
bâtons de sérieux dans les roues quel
modèle choisir malgré ça alors lui c'est
peut-être ces cesu craignant de le dire
mais ils essayent ils espèrent
pour se rapprocher de l'ouest c'est une
question de sécurité c'est le grand le
coeur du débat avec la russie et c'est
aussi une question là encore de modèle
de société se rapprocher de l'est et de
l'ouest pardon c'est pas forcément aller
à bruxelles c'est adopter des standards
qui serait plus ceux de l'europe par
exemple en termes d'état de droit et
concrètement c'est quoi c'est quand on
est un citoyen avoir celui droit à son
statut de citoyen avoir le droit de
s'adresser à une police normal à une
justice normale ce qui n'est pas le cas
à ce que je montre moins dans mon livre
ce que c'est que la réalité non vous
n'êtes pas un citoyen comme vous vivez
dans un pays corrompu à ce point là un
mois enfin sur un autre sujet a
peut-être parce que je crois que c'est
un sujet qui vous tient à coeur du jeune
homme auquel vous d dédié ce livre qui
s'appelle nikita ouvarov et sur lequel
vous avez beaucoup écrit il a 16 ans et
vient de sibérie pour le coup en russie
il vient d'être condamné à cinq ans de
prison pour avoir voulu faire sauter le
siège du fsb dans le jeu vidéo minecraft
qu'est-ce que son histoire en quelques
mots dits la russie d'aujourd'hui oh
c'est difficile elle dit on pourrait
parler de plein de choses elle parle
d'une génération qui est en fait à peu
près la même que partout dans le monde
un à doa dans une ville de sibérie une
ville particulière de sibérie ans et
sombre c'est dur le plafond est très
très bas on va dire
mais il a les mêmes références les mêmes
rêves que un ado de paris ou de
n'importe où ils s'informent sur
internet alors l'umih se trouve qu'ils
avaient des sympathies anarchistes mais
j'imagine comme on peut en avoir à 15
ans sauf que là bas dans cette ville ce
que je ce que je disais avec cette image
compliquée du plafond bas c'est que
révèle liberté c'est compliqué et être
un rebelle c'est encore plus compliqué
qu'ailleurs et ça se paye par la prison
en l'occurrence pour un marché vidéo non
pas pour avoir joué un jeu vidéo selon
les enquêtes pour avoir eu des projets
d'attentats mais
l'instruction présente comme projet
d'attentats le plus abouti effectivement
ce cette idée vaguement lancé dans un
chat avec des copains farah des sinon le
fsb dans ce jeu minecraft et faisons le
sauter 50 prison donc nikita oumarov à
qui vous dédiez se livrent les louer à
sa mère d'ailleurs qui vient de sortir
aux arènes vous l'avez compris on fait
n'a fait des allers retours entre la
russie et l'ukraine 2022 et 2012 c'est
noir noir c'est noir mais c'est
passionnant merci beaucoup et benoît
vitkine merci d'être venu ce matin sur
le plateau de paris direct qu'on vous
lis bien sûr dans le monde quand vous
serez de retour à moscou d'ici là bon
séjour en france